so constructive institutionalism
is when leaders sit down and act like
everything's gonna work out
even though by the numbers there's no
reason to think that it will work out
and they make you feel good and they
make you feel good and so wow he was so
inspiring yeah we're not doing [ __ ]
but i feel good and every organization's
interests are toward constructive
institutionalism because you know
it'll just make you feel better uh and
government is so guilty of this all the
time i was i said to a
group of business leaders the other day
i was like look you've all been named to
these government honorary advisory
boards and whatnot and we know you do
not do [ __ ] you get together you take a
photo op it looks like everyone's on
board and you go home and you do nothing
so that that's the nature of the problem
uh that i defined as constructive
institutionalism in my book and i got to
say that chapter i wrote down like the
middle of the night where i was like
having dark souls
and then i woke up the next morning
being like i'm gonna read what i wrote
and see if it it's like
you know
uh acceptable and it ended up being one
of my favorite it's your best chapter i
would argue that's a chapter that why
definitely for me and probably youtube
why you ran for president why i joined
you why i just clicked
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back me and zach
are in the studio to talk the trump's
back
constructive institutionalism what the
heck is that
why
so many of us don't know where to turn
to for information or news anymore but
let's get started with the news that was
all over the internet and
mainstream
news sources
trump has a special purpose acquisition
company it's a bit of a gimmick it's a
bit of a gimmick so so for those of you
who don't know what a stack is check it
out okay a spec is you go to the public
markets and say hey
we're raising money
to buy a private company to be named
later sometime in the next two years to
do whatever we sketch our plan out to be
now sometimes the plans aren't that
shall we say robust
and in this case though
this company was meant to start true
social media a whole new parallel social
media network or plural networks so
think a new facebook a new twitter
new netflix a new netflix wow i didn't
know that was that there yeah it's
social and then digital like streaming
content wow no wonder they raised so
much money trump
media and technology group tmtg
has raised the ipod at
9.96 94 somewhere around there
and at one point it was over 94 dollars
in terms of was trading that's uh
a lot of money that has raised and it's
a bit of a meme stock too so those who
follow wall street bets which we've
covered on this show
uh you may have gotten in on this and we
will not
say this is a good investment or not i'm
going to please no investment advice
here
on the forward podcast so
this is a fascinating play i think most
of us are immediately dubious
because trump has a storied track record
of throwing his name on businesses that
may be more sizzled than steak shall we
say nice trump staying
there so
i saw this
and thought to myself who in the trump
universe could possibly
create a facebook rival or a twitter
rival or a netflix rival and the answer
is nobody knows uh you know like it's
unclear whether they could muster the
type of talent and personnel
to get that done because a lot of the
tech talent frankly does not want to
hang out with the
trump universe and throw their name on
things i mean there is this real
sense of
you know um
polarization
um shall we say and uh on this side i
will say that
uh i'm dubious
i'll throw that out there now whether
they can pull this off
um but there there is something really
interesting and powerful about this
uh where you do have these quasi
monopolies that now are valued at let's
call it a trillion dollars plus right
and so if someone credible comes along
and makes a business case that we can
create a challenger to the monopoly uh
investors can legitimately get excited
and imagine it uh becoming very very
valuable
if you're speculative you're a venture
investor or you're high risk high reward
type this makes sense to you know
because the upside is very very high um
i would say so i
read the deck i read the pitch deck
there's some homework for this episode
who knew that zach worked on wall street
so you don't have to so here's what it
says they're going to do the the tmtg
i'm a quote here aspires to create a
media powerhouse to rival the liberal
media consortium and fight back against
the big quote big tech close-quote
companies of silicon valley who have
used their unilateral power to silence
opposing voices in america
and so
and if you look through this there's a
bunch of media headlines talking about
how facebook twitter amazon wikipedia
apple and stripe have all banned donald
trump or conservative personalities they
did have an interesting point where
twitter banned donald trump but
allowed the spokesperson from the
taliban to keep their account so
i get some of the frustration if you
will on that side um
they talked about
every major media outlet in the united
states so they started with newspapers
and then radio and cable tv and now
social media eventually splits on
ideological lines and they had a bunch
of examples of this and this is the
point that they're making is that
they're going to lead the newest split
um
here's my one comment i will say it did
look like a lot of decks i had made back
on um did you make this deck exactly i
did not make this deck my point was that
i could have made this deck was that it
was one of those decks that like tells a
fun story but there's no meat and so any
real investor be like that sounds great
show me your numbers um or in this case
they're just essentially betting the
thing i would think would be like show
me the team show me like who the heck is
actually going to build this correct so
a couple fun things so slide 9 is just a
graph of the u.s population
growing
saying that because the population
bigger it will be ripe for further
segmentation that was hilarious i would
say that that makes a pretty good
business case for starting anything
under the sun you know so there's more
people you can do more business yang's
umbrella co here's a slide more people
more need
uh one was just showing how many social
media followers trump has uh
146.6 million across twitter facebook
and instagram um
slide 11 is actually helpful to size the
digital media market whether it's
netflix or
uh twitter or various listen to youtube
you want to invest in this thing i like
the macro play i really i mean like
realistically like there's a so this is
the first thing that came to mind for me
and this this might be a sign of how my
brain works it's not a great comparison
at all but it reminded me of people
making the case for starting a rival um
professional wrestling outfit because
wwe had a had a quasi monopoly and it
was worth a billion bucks and i was like
well you can't have a monopoly yeah and
then they try and start a new wrestling
league the problem is that a lot of the
dynamics in that industry kind of steer
everyone towards the same place because
the the dominant player ends up
absorbing a bunch of the talent
um and so
you know i it this is going to be
fascinating i think that there's been a
real miss in terms of the public
discussion of what we should be
concerned about where social media
companies are concerned right
yeah so conservatives are like hey
censorship it's like oh if you look at
like the top
you know 10 20 100 accounts on facebook
a lot of them are conservative
conservative content does really well in
these social media networks right
and so it doesn't seem like there's any
kind of systematic stamping out of
news sources from particular sides or
whatnot actually if anything
you know there's a
stop
uh hate on facebook campaign which made
the opposite argument where it said that
facebook was too easy on various
conservative outlets so i'm not sure
that that is the issue though i know
that a lot of conservatives uh make that
case i think the more prevalent issues
uh are that the social media networks
are just really bad for our mental
health and it's just oppressing the heck
out of people
uh it's most clear with younger people
but it's true of everyone you know even
evelyn just the other day was you know
off social media for a while then went
back on social media for a little bit to
promote something and then came out and
was like man like that that was not
exactly
you know like uh it didn't really boost
our spirits for the day let's put it
that way so your point that like
conservative content does well and has
no problem getting microphone generally
is true my the bigger challenge and i
think we'll talk about this more in this
episode is like narrative stuff so i
believe that there are very real
biases to be reckoned with uh but i i
was making the case that if there are a
couple things i'm most deeply concerned
about where social media networks are
concerned it's less this it's more
number one is
the the erosion and disintegration of
our mental health number two would be
the complete fragmentation of
information where at this point truth is
whatever the heck my filter bubble says
it is so they're like 24 different
truths so we can't have a shared
conversation
it's the fact that our democracy is
being subverted where you have foreign
actors who are just ginning us up
against each other uh and using these
tools to kind of expose this underbelly
we have where we're not very
uh
together as a society shall we say right
and so the splintering um can have
really negative yeah even disastrous
effects so those are some of the things
that come to mind for me first uh and
that there are a handful of
voices that have run afoul of the
standards of the social media companies
strikes me as
an issue to be sure but when i talk to
the folks at the social media companies
about that issue they look and say look
we don't even want to be making these
decisions yeah it's just right now
they're being forced into making these
decisions because they've become the de
facto public square and our government's
nowhere to be found our government's
essentially like do what you want um
regulate yourselves regulate yourselves
and then know we're going to yell at you
for whatever decision you make and then
the tech companies are like well do you
want to make this decision and then the
government's like oh we could never make
that decision you know and so you're
like well
you know we get hurt yeah it's kind of a
lose-lose because wherever they draw the
line someone's going to get mad right um
so that's you know that uh back to the
trump's back
it's a fascinating business case
um a lot of these social media networks
genuinely do hue towards winner take all
where frankly if there's like a place i
go like i'm on twitter a lot of everyone
knows that uh you know one of the
benefits is that everyone else is on
twitter you know what i mean yeah and so
like if someone said hey andrew here's a
new new social media network and i'd go
there
and i find out that you know 80 of the
people that i know of are not there then
i'd be like well this is kind of
not very awesome not very it's very hard
to overcome
that network effect as a new player you
would gen generally if you were a
company trying to do this you would seat
it with awesome people yeah you'd be
like come here and then all of a sudden
pay you whatever yeah yeah that's right
and and that is one of the things you're
seeing in this space is that they are
running around trying to pay certain
influencers to seed some of these social
media networks and even then it's a real
uphill battle it's a real slog so a
couple things from this deck and then
we'll shift gears so on this deck they
talked and this is theirs this is the um
trump media um and technology groups
survey but one of the poll they showed
was that a third of the country would
use a trump
social media platform one-third so
that's 54 of republicans 24 independents
and even 12 percent of democrats i'd
argue if you're
using the trump social media platform
you're probably not really a team
democrat democratic maybe you're there
just to mess around i don't know yeah
who knows um
so i i would say like from a macro
standpoint yeah this is actually
interesting the bigger one to me is is
less about to your point on social media
like that's always hard um
and if it's just a right-wing bubble
then
are you thinking the content you think
in new movie studios yeah i think that
the tmtg plus streaming content is
interesting um in the sense that
like if you are not a liberal
and you watch the oscars you're not
loving it right you are feeling and
there's certain types of content that
have become you're you're feeling the
preacher or feel like it's politicized
um and if you're super against it you're
hating it and if you're moderate you're
seeing it right so there is a market for
i think um
either more neutral or more more
conservative leaning
like general what this is exactly
execution what this makes me think of is
christian content yeah comes out and
sometimes you have these hit movies
uh uh and albums and whatnot
that
aren't considered
uh i suppose mainstream even though some
of them have vast audiences that's what
occurred to me good point though i'm not
sure if
the this uh trump world content is going
to mirror christian content it is very i
was raised christian and i am a
christian and it is very difficult for
me to see anything christ like in what
donald trump does that drives me that's
absolutely bonkers at the evangelical
right he's like donald trump's our guy
are you kidding me like come on anyway
that's not the point right here pj but i
agree
um and i think if you're a parent you're
watching the little nas video
of like you know him literally as the
devil um doing various things i i don't
think there's a lot of parents like i
don't want that for my my child right um
for better or for worse and that's your
opinion but there there is a market for
it i think there's certainly i mean
it's going to be fascinating to see
another thing this makes me think of is
that i think they made a movie with gina
carano as soon as disney canceled her
uh that's right yeah so they'll they'll
take some canceled figures so wait wait
let's make a list just for fun
um so the
the new programming
would star kevin spacey
gina
is actually a battlefield i don't like i
mean no i mean i'm just staring out
there it's like which is a bummer
because i loved kevin's who would be
like the cancelled greatest gal gadot
got kind of hammered oh is still very
very she's still doing things up um
gal's going to be roseanne
would be there roseanne uh
terry crews
terry crews got canceled oh yeah he's a
republican
i think terry crews got cancelled there
we go so it would uh also terry crews
would be there
kelsey grammer's there
chappelle would be there i guess hell
would totally not be there you gotta be
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
there'll be nowhere near this you're
right that's the thing like a lot of
these folks
like you have actual [ __ ] who
deserve to be canceled and they would
get you know mopped up here and then you
have people who are not [ __ ] who
have been quote unquote cancelled or
like gotten in hot water and they
wouldn't want to be associated with
the don i mean essentially
anyone who can just hop on the
mainstream
um
media offerings uh will stay there yeah
the people that
can't get
that kind of booking will come here
so i it was sort of fun for me to think
about who those figures are yeah
[Music]
my name is kiernan shipka i play the
role of ali in the new podcast treat a
new movie length podcast from c13
features
[Music]
there's something coming to ali west's
not-so-perfect little town
[Music]
a new kind of listening experience
these things they're not kids john
you're not making sense
we have to hide there's nowhere left to
hide treat a podcast movie from c13
features a cadence 13 studio
you can experience treat releasing
everywhere on october 25th for free on
apple podcast spotify odyssey and
wherever you listen to your podcast
grab some popcorn and enjoy the show
[Music]
where they'll make their money is
probably the content like if they can
raise enough money which looks like they
are to produce shows and the shows are
good people watch them not everyone they
don't have to like donald trump has a
big enough audience we'd get enough
people to persuade some advertisers and
look there's a reason oan exists there's
a reason newsmax exists there are
advertisers and a lot of people that
watch that stuff so if you're just pure
business objective i think you know
i don't think this is going away
the point i have was earlier was like
it's giving me an execution thing and i
don't think that donald has proven great
execution on a lot of businesses that he
is running it depends he slaps his name
on hotel i'm going to suggest that i i
think that you can make an ideological
cable news offering and make it a more
viable business
more easily than you could trying to
produce genuine scripted content because
if you think about conservative talk
radio very low cost you can get an
audience uh even some of these
upstart new cable news offerings pretty
low cost you get a studio yeah pretty
much as long as you get like the
uh the distribution channel then you're
off to the races
um but if you have scripted content i
mean that stuff gets expensive it's very
hard to do well
um high risk people have very high
standards for it it's very high risk and
so if you look at even major hollywood
movies or tv shows or whatnot
well you know we're in a funny time
because now who knows what's profitable
but
but a lot of them have a hard time
turning a profit and they have let's say
80 percent of the sandbox to play in or
something like good point um so if if
you start out with 15 of the sandbox and
say hey make some movies make some tv
shows like i think you're [ __ ]
personally
as you can tell so so that that that's
andrew's take on it
my take would be
i like the concept of talking to
a broader part of the country i don't
like the concept of
in talking them you're making donald
trump more rich well i think that you
can
again you can build on those existing
business models like could they start a
fledgling cable channel i'd believe it
yeah you know could they start
um well social media is tough because on
that one um you know i mean that stuff
is advertising driven so they're having
a smaller sandbox will again really hurt
you
um yeah as you can tell i'm dubious
about their ability to get into some of
these traditional
um
businesses successfully one downside and
probably should talk about this is that
if it let's say he wins presidency in
2024 which is
something we've talked about this
becomes like an authoritarian mouthpiece
of [ __ ]
um
which feels a little scary that would be
very bizarre where the the president's
like i only talk on to channel trump
yeah and then i would be like on channel
trump today and trump said this and then
he's making money off it you know one
thing that does irk me is that you know
like we we do things i mean i've run
campaigns have started organizations and
whatnot and we always have these like
massive compliance teams being like yo
you know gotta do this right here do
that right and then when it comes to
trump and the gang they're like seems
like yeah like no rules at all and
everyone's like he's breaking the rules
and then they're like no one's enforcing
them they're not really rules then yeah
which does bring us to i think one of
the things that has fed trump this
entire time there's something i talk
about in my book
uh and i had to come up with a name for
it so that i love this name although i
forget it a lot no so the the so the
name of this idea
is constructive institutionalism which i
actually made purposefully benign
because i wanted someone to be able to
use it with someone else without seeming
like they're insulting you oh yeah yeah
yeah and also the people that are guilty
of constructive institutionalism would
totally use the phrase constructive
institutionalism that's what i was going
for
so what the heck am i talking about and
i think that this is something that
really feeds
the rise of trump and people that think
that all the
you know media are [ __ ] and then all
these institutions are [ __ ] uh and
so this was something i had to kind of
dig deep on and it was born
in part of a comment from eric weinstein
a little while ago where he said that
this economy is making liars of us all
and then you asked him well what do you
mean by that and he said well you have
these institutions that pretend that
they're going to give the academics
tenure that they're going to make the
new lawyers partners eventually and then
later they have to come back and be like
yeah turns out those positions don't
exist okay yeah and now you're in
you know this permanent purgatory as an
adjunct or your
lawyer forever who will never make
partner and and
so you have
all of these assumptions around growth
that if they don't hold true
then you're you're having to lie to a
lot of people
in various ways
and i thought that he was right
and i realized that it's happening
around us all the time
and it also built into some of my own
experiences where i would do countless
interviews or
sit on a panel and then i get asked a
question
that kind of presupposes
that it's going to work out so here's a
here's one that you all will have heard
a million times how are we going to
ensure that growth is equitable and
includes people of different backgrounds
and then i process that and then the way
i answer on a panel is like well we have
to really you know work hard to uh find
the people that right now are being left
behind and make sure they have access to
this it's and if you can see
like the real answer is we will not
you know if someone says like how are we
going to
retrain millions of americans for the
jobs of the future the answer is we will
not how are we going to overcome
polarization almost certainly will not
how are we going to you know like all of
these big problems but the way it's
framed to you it's kind of a difficult
problem yeah yeah well one it's
presented to you as a solvable problem
and then you virtue signal by saying
like well we gotta dig deep and make
sure that people that aren't getting uh
to the table right now get there and
then we all go home and no one actually
is going to go and try and find the
person who's not at the table and bring
them to the table so i've been a part of
these
gatherings all the time and we do just
kind of [ __ ] each other the kabuki
or the pantomime becomes the deliverable
where it's like as long as i showed up
to the session
and said the right things and made the
right
value statements then everyone's like
okay
uh we're working on it and then everyone
goes home and thinks about and i've
obviously been a part of this so you
know to the extent that there's like any
um responsibility or or complicity or
whatnot i mean certainly i'd raise my
hand and say yeah like i've done this
[ __ ] i raised my countless times this
was ubs so i would bring we have
billionaires in the room i would invite
you
and a bunch of other social
entrepreneurs thanks for the information
i'm on the panel and the goal is to
raise money make connections to help
your org because you're doing great work
and the panel goes like this
andrew
you've done something something
incredible tell me about how your
program works and you just kind of do
the pitch of why vfa is awesome tell a
couple fun stories charm the crowd but
at no point would it be appropriate for
me to be like
yeah your program's not really working
what are the actual core problems with
it and why can't we fix it you know at a
fundamental level i would never ask that
because one you're doing me a favor and
the organization a favor by coming um
and two then we all kind of look bad and
so there's like your point is this this
like nonsense not talking about the
elephant in the room which is
philanthropies broken the people in the
room that can do something about it
either don't know or don't care or can
do nothing that's probably one of the
three or the scale is wrong and that's
one of the things that drove me is that
if you look at the largest non-profit in
the country i think its entire budget is
in the hundreds of millions something
along those lines yeah if you're
excluding like big hospitals i guess
yeah i i'd have to look at that i mean i
guess if you had hospitals you'd
probably find somewhere like
universities maybe oh universities don't
get me started i mean there'd be like 20
universities with a billion dollar
endowments for sure
but if you look at annual budgets of
operating non-profits uh i think the
highest budgets are in the let's say
hundreds of millions and then if you
look at the scale of the economy it's 22
trillion uh and so
yeah so if you have and so it you know
and i ran an organization that was
um in the like the low millions um but
like our ability to effectuate real
change at the right scale
uh would be close to zero yeah and
so and you were doing great work as
someone who had to find the people doing
good work
i mean
i can count on on two hands maybe of
like really innovative new work
that's not a knock on people or doing
you know wonderful saint-like work but
in terms of new innovative pushing the
envelope there weren't a lot of people
doing it even you were like yeah scales
off well and so people
at home zach also started a non-profit
and that's extraordinarily wholesome
called suit up volunteer suit up i'll
plug it if you guys are looking for a
better volunteer day we do a really good
job um and we'll be a million dollar
organization but a year it's crazy dude
started out like 200 bucks so what so
what suit up does is it pairs struggling
school kids with professional mentorship
opportunities where they they get
presentations from people who are in
professional environments to try and get
their heads up to the fact that there
are real opportunities out there if they
stay in school and try and do good work
and you structure it like they're
instead of your park cleanup or soup
kitchen you do a one-day volunteer day
where
like it since a company like signs up
for this and pays for it and then the
kids get real world you know mentorship
and access and that company gets a
better way to volunteer however same
problem like scale
both there's too many students um
yeah like when we were doing them in
person we couldn't you know too many
schools to work with and two
companies have like this much budget
like a small sliver of their budget is
meant for employee engagement
um
which is not a ton of money it's usually
ten percent of their overall
philanthropic budget and their
philanthropic budget of course is uh
also small so you're not talking about
at large so
zach and i have each started it sounds
like uh
what will either
be soon or are million dollar
non-profits multi-million
non-non-profits and and both of us
realize that we needed to go bigger to
try and solve the fundamental problems
are getting hairier and more
far-reaching and more serious all the
time so constructive institutionalism
is when leaders sit down and act like
everything's going to work out
even though by the numbers there's no
reason to think that it will work out
and they make you feel good and they
make you feel good and so wow he was so
inspiring yeah we're not doing [ __ ]
but i feel good and every organization's
interests are toward constructive
institutionalism because you know
it's it'll just make you feel better uh
and government is so guilty of this all
the time i was i said to a
group of business leaders the other day
i was like look you've all been named to
these government honorary advisory
boards and whatnot and we know you do
not do [ __ ] you get together you take a
photo op it looks like everyone's on
board and you go home and you do nothing
and really savvy business leaders you
know sometimes do it just so that it
seems and you get to hang out with other
business leaders so yeah there's never
selfish gain but in terms of actually
like you know moving [ __ ] it's like very
very seldom right do these things uh
actually have uh real impact or
deliverables even some of like the major
commitments when you go to some of these
conferences they'll say it's like look
just commit the thing you were going to
do anyway
and then and there's very little in the
way of follow-up none
right like it's almost never like hey
like did he do the thing did he do that
he was not a good thing
i think people sense this so there's a
lot of [ __ ] going on really and then
so when someone runs around let's call
him donald trump and calls [ __ ]
there are a lot of people that are like
oh yeah it is [ __ ] like why is
college going up in price every [ __ ]
year like why is my health care
going
you know like they're they're real
freaking problems and then if you get
people from the institutions in there
like no one's like oh yeah like we're
we're really shafting the hell out of
people we've been we're doing it at
scale you know like and and so there's
this real fervor around trying to change
things and it's getting channeled in
very very uh destructive and
unconstructive ways in part because the
people who man or staff or run these
institutions can't do anything about
these deep problems because none of
their incentives aren't standing up and
saying yeah you know that that this is
actually fundamental uh it's more like
oh we're working on this thing check it
out we've got this initiative and you
know we're spending whatever like half
of one percent of our company's budget
on it and we're gonna have an event
around it and then we'll get some people
to say nice things so that that's the
nature of the problem uh that i defined
as constructive institutionalism in my
book and i gotta say that chapter i
wrote down like the middle of the night
where i was like having dark souls
and then i woke up the next morning
being like i'm gonna read what i wrote
and see if it it's like
you know
uh acceptable and it ended up being one
of my favorite it's your best chapter i
would argue that's a chapter that why
definitely for me and probably youtube
why you ran for president why i joined
you why i just clicked
[Music]
so when i started suit up i was
part-time at ubs but i um
or sorry i was full-time at ubs was
part-time running this organization and
the number one thing people said to me
was uh and it was really humbling at
first like oh that's so impressive like
how do you find the time to do that and
my gut reaction to that is like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about these kids
are screwed like they have nothing like
why why are we doing nothing like stop
brunching on the weekends and maybe help
out a little bit and it was
and that's literally how i found time it
was like like you skipped i didn't drink
as much on saturday at 11 a.m and look
that is fun i do like a good brunch who
doesn't um but that was what was driving
me nuts um and
we have a very
it's it's not as simple as like the the
one percent elitists it's i mean it's
bigger than that it's like our corporate
culture where people are working and
we're all market actors right we're all
market actors and we're just we talk
about this stuff we feel good we go to
the gala we pay our thing we go to the
open bar
but we just don't give a [ __ ] um or what
i call it was light commitment
benevolence like i'll do enough so that
i can feel good but i'm not better than
average but i'm not but i'm not going to
like make a meaningful
uh sacrifice i'm not going to like bet
the rent you know i mean like i'll i'll
do something where i can show up to your
thing and
um and have a couple drinks let me ask
you this um so i was just on
uh adam carolla's podcast it's called
take a knee um which andrew is going on
soon he's going on the main one i got i
got like the jv one i think it's behind
the pay wall but it was fun adam's like
an interesting
interesting character um but a good guy
he's nice to me and i was grateful to be
on there one thing he said
in this was that i'm curious your
thoughts he said
so i was talking about my mom was a
teacher and my dad went into business as
an engineer and and he said
don't over hype the saint move because
those who do go into business and create
thousands of job and play millions in
taxes or whatever that sort of thing
there is a lot of good arguably a lot
more good done by contributing economy
at that scale and i
i heard him say that i thought like on
one hand there's a lot of truth to that
like building things does add a ton of
value but i didn't think it was
fundamentally true and i feel like
you're smarter than me to understand why
i was kind of like
on that like thoughts on that push back
on
instead of maybe building the schools
it's better to create a whole bunch of
jobs and that
rising tide will lift all boats wow i
literally wrote a book called smart
people should build things yeah trying
to lionize folks who actually go out and
do yeah
like great jobs and because he was like
that person one of the greatest jobs is
vilified more today i don't know
somewhat he's not wrong about that i
mean you know like we certainly are down
on
business people it's very hard to start
stuff in a way yeah i mean i
admire people who started a business at
any level you know lemonade stands hard
diners
it's super hard
i i don't think there's anything wrong
with trying to hold up folks who work in
jobs that serve the public good then
about jobs that come to mind for me like
teachers or firefighters
or
nurses or people that you know that
you're probably a caring individual if
you're there ministering to to folks or
teaching our kids or whatnot and we
should pay him it should be a living
healthy wage we should like we should be
paying a lot of they shouldn't be
worried too much about money right yeah
i admit i have a feeling and this is one
of the themes of my campaign is like you
know do you want me to say nice [ __ ]
about you or do you want me to give you
money and everyone would be like give me
your mind please yeah i'd rather be an
[ __ ] but give me money right yeah
agreed yeah because everybody's kind of
an [ __ ] at some point right and that
is one of the diseases is like we just
get pressured into the virtue signal of
being like oh you know like essential
like thank you it's like the the workers
don't care what the [ __ ] you call them
if you just give them some more money
and like that would be preferable than
like having us all be like you're
essential or you know thank you it's
like you know i can thank you by being
being willing to pay more so that you
can bring some more home to your family
you've talked about before it's like
when you're an employer
when you have
uh an employee you want to take care of
them you can do a couple things you can
tell them good job
uh you can promote them or you can pay
them more money and those are like your
three options i think i'm doing it right
yeah
number one really is do nothing
but but the one that will like the other
things can work temporarily but the only
thing that works long term is more money
all right that's a good segue andrew
wait wait wait i'm gonna put the forward
party hat on because we're gonna put the
thinking cap on and we're gonna talk
about we're gonna talk about the thing
that so many people talk about which is
what is going on with our news media
and why
do people feel like they have no idea
where to go to get information they can
trust oh uh it's a good segue because
both the trump's media company and
constructive institutionalism all kind
of play into all of the problems their
media first though plug for the forward
merch you're looking pretty good man the
hat's actually pretty cool well thank
you i i feel very
uh
heroic and patriotic there it is
feeling you know what i mean you look
kind of heroic i like it oh thank you um
the captain america vibe going there you
go all right i did watch uh
flying back from l.a i watched the last
avengers again uh and i always cry at
the end uh because robert downey jr and
spider-man iron man spider-man always
gets me that's not the point what the
hell's wrong with the media we both made
lists you let's see you go first because
we know anyone listening this knows
they're going to be smarter than
whatever i come up with
well the the major problem with the news
media right now is the commercial
incentives where if
you
try and present something in an
even-handed objective way
it's
less enticing and people reward you
less by coming to you
and so the more kind of red meat you
throw someone's away the more
excited they get
if you push the envelope a bit if you're
a little more sensationalist if you're a
bit more ideological there was an msnbc
producer ariana bakari who said that if
they had a peaceful protest and a
protest with some flames or violence
they would just show the flames and
violence over and over again obviously
and then they would cut away from
anything peaceful because they were like
well this is some boring programming so
you can see that incentive playing out
in pretty much every media organization
you can name car crash right when you
think about the news media in my opinion
right now you think about cable news
because they're so dominant
and when i was running for president
they felt like the only game in town
very very often because if you go on a
news program of another network let's
call it abc or whatnot you're not going
to go back on that network for
weeks maybe months because they can't
just keep talking to you
but cable news you could go on you know
different shows uh five six times in a
given week
and so it feels like they're they're the
only game in town uh and they are
definitely very
um
ideological uh in invent
uh certainly fox and msnbc you can just
look at the numbers and and see
um and
that's i think problem number one is
just that you get rewarded for being a
little bit more aggressive uh
sensationalist and ideological and if
that's the way your organization gets
rewarded that's where you're going to go
and it kind of tracks the human nature
now like we like
the excitement piece or if you're going
to take time out of your day to read
something it's
more instinctive that you'll find we've
all definitely come to it you know what
i mean yeah like and so i'm going to to
take the next ingredient which is social
media
and studies have shown that
negative sentiment and falsehood spread
six times more quickly and powerfully on
social media than truth
[Laughter]
so if you're
an organization that again pushes the
envelope you're more likely to get
clicks and traffic
and any content producer will tell you
i'm you know i produce content you know
what you do after you produce content
wait to see how many people look at it
you know you produce a video it's like
oh many people watch that video
how many people are going to listen to
this podcast
and so over time you start thinking oh
if i get a little bit zanier like a
little bit more title it this way you're
just all just pandering the youtube
algorithm or whatever a matter of fact
zach we should trash someone right now
just to get get some numbers oh yeah we
want trash uh
that [ __ ] tom brady screw you oh wow
we can both pile on tom brady good stuff
good stuff good choice good job
on sunday
so my so my list goes number one
commercial incentives and then number
two social media
incentives that also are commercial but
are a little bit more personal and human
i had um
that it's
factual but not accurate
well that always bothered me so we
talked about this when people say
numerous sources or many people had said
but it's also this one that i love where
a fringe outlet or small young quote
unquote journalist writes a click bait
piece
um for let's call it business insider or
the verge or one of these like smaller
uh outlets
and then
washington post new york times or cable
news can pay can be accusations have
been made of blank right so not like
they're not saying
that the story's true but it is true
that an accusation was made even if that
accusation was fundamentally false and i
don't think people realize
the layers of
like how far it's like it's almost like
telephone like how far away you get from
the truth
um media reporting on other media is
certainly on this list of major problems
because there's a desire not to get
scooped
and so if someone else reports something
then you're like oh we gonna pile on
this thing and the answer often now
tends to be yes even if as you're
describing zach you're like well
all i'm gonna do is
represent to you
this
reporting
that may or may not be true right but
i'm just going to present it to you and
you can't attack me because you know it
happened you know the other article
happened
um even though we have no idea whether
it's [ __ ] or not and we had
had no contact with any primary source
and we have nothing to add yeah but
we're just going to report on the
reporting there's like a lot of this
meta stuff
um and it feeds into this new cycle of
the day feeding frenzy that something
kind of flimsy can get put out there
particularly if again it's kind of
negative and sensationalism and everyone
will be like oh well we can't just
ignore it like we have to let our
readers know that this is happening
oh you'll get the my favorite from the
reporters is i'm going live with the
story whether you like it or not and i'm
like well i have 10 people on record
they'll say the exact opposite who are
better closer to the source or xyz like
i'm going live with the story regardless
do you have a comment can my comment be
i have 10 people close to the source
that'll say the exact opposite no i'm
not including that quote then i don't
know what to tell you like that is like
there's a very real conversation i've
had multiple times um
now we get you know you it was you know
the context there is you're getting shiv
for god knows what um um for having
building built things i guess in your
past um there's a there is a
journalistic code like it exists where
they don't reveal their sources and they
they do fact check but the fact check
can be someone else said something
another media outlet quoted this so
that's enough of a source for me so that
is one of my biggest
um
concept of fact issues i have with the
media
um well so what you just suggested zack
is a dynamic that probably should be on
the list
so journalists have sources and
relationships and one of the things that
political operatives do in particular is
just try and feed a story to a friendly
journalist and the journalist can either
take it or not take it right
and so this happened certainly
in the mayoral campaign all the time
where if you had five
uh other candidates like their entire
day was spent trying to source negative
stories about oh yeah about other
candidates in that case it was often me
because i was the most conspicuous
candidate at that time
so if you're a journalist you're like
huh okay you're trying to have me print
something
is it true
well yeah i can defend it
journalistically yeah
i can defend it it's defensible not
truth yeah am i
going to preserve my relationship with
you by
uh helping you out with this story and
thus maybe get something from you later
that will help me do my job yes so let
me so okay defensible
kind of helps me maybe i've known you
for a while
yeah let's do it
and then you can and then that ends up
producing things that objectively are
like wait why is that news or why is
that newsworthy or like doesn't that
seem incomplete right and that's a very
real thing that's one reason why
you hire people whose job it is to have
relationships with reporters they can
work them
[Music]
okay if you're a candidate you're
running a campaign which by definition
is a temporary organization right so it
doesn't exist after the election or
after a couple elections depending on
you right um
so therefore
these entire
infrastructures are just
being created and dying right and so the
so what is the political institution
that exists it's the media right
and then it's consultants who become
basically experts in various
aspects of politics so you'll have a
pollster that's
an expert in polling and you'll have a
press consultant there's a bunch of
relationships a lot of supporters then
you'll have a tv ads person you'll have
a digital media firm and an email expert
all these folks
and
they plug into candidates as they pop up
and the candidates hire them these sort
of things and they have professional
relationships with the media
so they are friends
the but the the other the thing that
cuts the other way is that those
reporters are not friends with the
campaign like they're not they're never
your friend they'll shiv you at any
point if they ever pretend to be your
friend they are not um
so it's
it cuts the wrong way where you have you
may be saying that's not true but your
xyz consultant and your team may be like
well may not be true but we can't bash
this reporter because
i need them down the road or i need them
for my other clients or god knows what
and so you end up in this very
precarious or confusing situation i
think where the incentives for you as a
candidate and the incentives for your
consultants are experts or institutional
you know political well they're they're
repeating players they you know they got
to think about the next client the next
job
uh
yeah yeah uh you know i made the same
comparison in the political side with
political consultants it's like there
are nfl coaches who would rather lose
professionally than have
anything high variance occur right so
that's why it seems like everyone's the
same yes yeah you'd rather like go
4 and 12 or whatever 4 and 13 i guess
not a 17 game then
uh
shoot for the shoot for the win but but
flame out right um
because no one wants no consultant must
be like oh you worked on that campaign
that was a disaster they'd much rather
abort
oh yeah you worked on
it and that and that's related to the
media stuff you're right because that
like the media and the handlers and the
consultants all have
a long-term relationship though i will
say that what you're describing is an
issue with specifically political media
but that's cool because a lot of people
listening to this will be like oh you
know yeah that's a political thing um
not so much in business media
at all you actually want to be friends
with the ceos and that certain startup
founders if you're a politic if you're a
business reporter right yeah i enjoy
business journalists for this reason
business journalists have kind of uh you
know more positive incentives um one
other issue i think is wrong with our
news today is just there's too much
freaking time
you know what i mean like when i was
growing up you had the evening news it's
like 30 minutes you had local news 30
minutes
now you have to fill what i guess 24
hours yeah uh of programming
and so if you gave me 24 hours to talk
about the news in a given day
i would make no sense by hour number
five
[Laughter]
which is one reason again why you have
like reporting on reporting and you have
like like the dynamics you do because
you just have so much time to fill
as a
product of the medium you have to have
these punchy five or six minute segments
with like visuals and
uh people coming in and out mina
everyone knows i think i was a
contributor to cnn for a while and like
i was like like a positive ingredient to
add to the mix it's like if you had a
show you would just be like hey let's
get yang on you can like talk
intelligently about what's going on in
capitol hill and policy for like six
minutes uh and uh you know i did my best
to do that and
like add value and say things that i
thought were
um
where were going to be a positive
contribution um but you just have so
much
time to fill
that you wind up i think
uh having to make certain types of
decisions
um because you have to keep it somewhat
interesting you have to talk about
things like they're important um you
know that are happening on a daily basis
one of the big things that i was trying
to make the case for on my presidential
campaign which i think this case really
needs to be made is that you have all
these deep-seated problems where we're
you know 28th in the world in infant
mortality or clean drinking water or
things but that there's nothing new it's
like there's no like news peg to that
where it's like yeah we still suck suck
you know suck again you know it's like
so like so like they're like the news
pegs are all like stock markets up or
like this person like is an [ __ ] and
then like and then so we're just running
i i feel like we're just getting
distracted and like just um getting uh
like these shiny objects like shown to
us on any given day while like the the
earth is turning into quicksand and then
more and more people are getting sucked
into the quicksand and you're seeing
different like cries for help and the
news media is just like
like what's wrong with you
like why are you not like
you know like why do you not like what
what we're saying uh
and
so that that would be
problem number i don't know where we are
on the list now maybe four is that
there's just like too much time for the
news uh you could throw in number five
that there is a visual medium and a
format
there is part of me that frankly is
somewhat flattered that i was considered
tv worthy
[Laughter]
i guess you know there are a lot of
people out there that are awesome
that probably aren't just aren't great
for like
frankly like like a commercial news
medium i got the face for radio or
whatever yeah you know what i mean and
so there's like something um
so skewed about the medium
um and then
my problem number six which is tied to
some of these things is there's this
sort of imperious authoritative
condescending
view that the media naturally takes
which i've summarized as get a load of
this guy or get a load of this person
and so there's this continued continuous
i don't the word that came to mind for
me is like shaming but there's like
there's just a lot of shaming going on
and so if you're an average person
looking up at this yeah like over time
you just begin to be like hey you know
maybe i'm i'm not maybe i'm more like
the person you're shaming than i am
you
like whoever you are
behind the camera and what this reminds
me of sarah palin back in back in 08 was
like the media elite the media
establishment and the rest of it and i
heard it at the time and you know
frankly i thought sarah palin was um you
know not just yeah like not very
um worth heating shall we say
but but there there is like a very real
tone and approach and condescension
uh and what what's interesting you and i
haven't spoken about this before maybe
we have a little bit so another theme of
my book is that running for office kind
of like puts you through a particular
kind of crucible
and it challenges your perspective and
mental health in a particular way you
know what really really challenges your
perspective and mental health
being on live television
five days a week for hours on end like
that stuff can really mess with your
head
now i know some of these people
obviously some of them are just as sane
as the day is long some of them are just
you know like anderson cooper is just a
really sane dude yeah he can be on
i like dana bash a tv
um yeah so some people are just very
very sane and it doesn't get to them but
other people
you can tell it's messed with them uh
and a lot of them too like you get in
that chair they you know frankly throw
makeup on you like a lot of the people
to
like you you know you kind of have to be
sort of like fixed in time like you're
in you have to be all perky you have to
be a certain level of perky to be on
camera and just going back on it over
and over again it does take something
out of you it takes a certain sort of
exertion and it messes with you
uh
and that there is a distortion that
occurs with the news media that when you
say like quote unquote like the media
elites like that like there is something
there and it's not necessarily anyone's
fault you know because you know again i
know some of these people
but
does that dynamic exist that where
they'll be caring about things that the
average person does not care about them
making a big deal out of things that
like you know a lot of people
don't care about 100 yeah
[Music]
it's become a commodity now and with the
advent of smartphones frankly and social
media in that in commodity in the sense
that anybody can create news and content
pretty easily um case in point yes this
you know forward
and wonder
and what's your differentiator then it's
like we had at ubs it was the two things
that helped our ubs like money
management anyone can manage your money
right um
but what was what kept ubs afloat was
trust whether it was fdic insured or the
scale or a lot of people use them and
then regulation which can be emote like
the government involvement could be a
moat around keeping business alive
and i think the connection between media
and our like mainstream media and our
government is what keeps them powerful
and trustworthy and um
and thriving in some ways or thriving
enough so this is my example and um
you don't i know you don't fully agree
but my example is catherine garcia in
the new york city mayor's race sure so
catherine garcia polling at these are
just facts pulling out essentially zero
low single digits um no social media
following
no name id
never been an elected official before
she's a government city government
operator um sanitation head not a
particularly compelling public speaker
or debater um and that's not my opinion
as like new york times was pretty harsh
on her and her baiting skills and other
outlets there were no unique marketing
tactics or anything out of the box or
out of the ordinary from the katherine
garcia campaign and had not raised a ton
of money there was nothing particularly
exceptional about catherine garcia
except one thing she was endorsed by the
new york times
and she went from low single digits to
the high 25 30 percent contending
with eric adams for the w extend with
you connecting everybody and almost one
and
that's the only thing
so
my point is there's still a power there
where if new york time says like you're
the guy you're the gal and you could go
from literally an uninspiring campaign
and we like her as a human um i believe
and you know we're better than i do yeah
i like catherine but she went from
literally
like a non-factor in the race at some
point with the blessing to a can major
contender um
do you think the media should have that
play i know their role is theoretically
to help educate the populace on what's
um you know who who they you should vote
for but
i don't know with today's information i
don't know if that's needed as much what
do you think there i personally
appreciated that they decided to get
behind catherine as opposed to some of
the other candidates but but to your
point
uh 69 percent of democrats have a high
trust in media
independence it's 36 republicans it's
only 15 percent you have this still
establishment heating
body of democratic voters who want to
hear from the news media who they should
support who's been blessed
and that's the dynamic the problem is
right now it's essentially an a
one-sided asymmetrical dynamic where
it's mainly true on the democratic side
probably inside does not care i don't
care and then there's like an increasing
body of people in the middle which i'm
going to throw myself in this body where
we're starting to become increasingly
concerned about what's going on uh in
terms of the establishment and the news
media's ability to present something
that's objective
um as opposed to being politically
motivated i mean that's why i think most
americans are at this point is like hey
like who do i trust like you know is
there a fix in for a particular group of
candidates and we certainly saw on the
democratic side they tried to shift
bernie at every turn in 16 and they
really successfully sandbagged him um
you saw kind of a repeat of that in 2020
to some extent you had different
candidates having different types of
treatment myself included
and like americans look at this and
we're like you know what like i get the
sense that there are some people trying
to put their thumb on the scale
uh and then the republican side you know
it's like all heck is breaking loose and
and you know trump kind of overrode a
lot of what people imagined as
institutional safeguards now the
institutions have uh decided that trump
is um the path
uh until further notice so
the issues are asymmetrical
when you ask like does the news media
have a rightful role in this
they are taking on this role 100 percent
they may they may or may not acknowledge
it all the time but they are 100 in the
tank for one candidate or another and
then they're just going to push push
push i almost appreciate them more when
they actually come out and say like hey
we're in the tank for this case i like
that too i like because there are pro
they're for profit companies so you know
let's be honest but that there is stuff
going on behind the scenes all the time
that i now realize where that you know
you have very very senior powers that be
at these organizations saying okay
here's who we're going to elevate here's
who we're going to ignore you know again
for us personally ariana picari the
msnbc producer said that she was
instructed
not to interview a number of candidates
including me
in 2019 and she was like no reason given
just hear some candidates don't talk to
them so so these things are going on in
news in these news media organizations
and it's one reason why people are
starting to check out or mistrust
we complained a lot on this podcast um
i like to be a podcast of action
thoughts on how to
start solving for this obviously a huge
issue i think
uh quickly say that i think you know we
are the right answer but like content
like our podcast is a step one i think
well so here's the
main premise that i want to operate on
that i think people are going to
recognize
people have lost trust in institutions
but you know who we trust
other people like anyone listening to
this as identified i think at least like
a few independent voices or journalists
were like okay like they're straight
shooters i'll believe them i might be
one of them and i thank you for it if
you decided that you trust me thank you
i'll do everything i can to live up to
that maybe you trust crystal maybe you
trust sauger or maybe you trust sam
harris maybe you trust i love peter
hamby he's my favorite peter hamby i
like peter too oh and tim alberto we had
on we're getting back on yeah so like
you've identified some journalists that
you like maybe maybe you've been
subscribed to their substance shepard
not brittany johnson that's friend sorry
pretty yeah maybe you've been subscribed
to their sub stack so here's what is
missing in american life and what i
actually am going to try and provide not
me individually but you know like
i want to build this thing is that we
need to build a constellation
of individuals that you trust
that can deliver you news and
information
in a way that is comparable to the way
it's happening from the traditional news
media on the left or the right it's like
this independent
provider of news that you can trust that
will
say very clearly
you know
if
there's like a relationship or a bias or
we get something wrong
um it'd be human you know what i mean
like people trust people and so if we
can get enough of those people together
and i want to be one of them
then we can try and solve this problem
and
this can help build a solution to what's
going wrong in our politics and our
society is
if people get some information that they
believe in that's objective that doesn't
succumb to some of these either
market-based or institutional biases
then we have a chance to bring everyone
back from the from the brink i hope
people are excited about this so the
forward party is the political
movement and then we're going to have a
media movement too this podcast is going
to be part of it and there's going to be
much much more to come but these are the
two projects i think are imperative for
our country to
make it through this hyperpolarized time
in a way it's like a search for truth
provision of truth uh and
try to make a case that look there is
some objective reality that's not
subject to my politics or ideology dare
i say it donald trump has inspired us
again
we were thinking of a media coming
before he did his but um
but yeah i i mean he inspired everyone
present now he's inspiring you that
oh wait a minute
i i knew we needed i knew we needed
i knew we needed this at some point when
like actually a friend said to me i have
no idea where to go to to get my
news
comment
a lot of people say that when i heard
that i i thought to myself he's right we
need to provide that so let's provide
that more to come i hope you're all
excited about that
hopefully we can solve some of the
problems in the news media that me and
zach just talked about amen um okay this
weekend's halloween i hope you guys
enjoy your halloween andrew it's your
wife's and your son's birthday
what's the plan man and what are you
gonna what are you gonna be for
halloween you're just gonna be andrew
yang
i could dress as myself i actually saw a
guy yesterday who said he's gonna dress
up as me and his wife's gonna dress up
as evelyn it's very cute
yeah that's approved by the way approved
halloween costume it's pretty easy you
know what you need all you need is a
blue blazer and a uh
um
oh my gosh is that
holy cow why do i look so horrified
horrifying if you can't see the video
it's worth you watching on youtube
because i bought this on amazon
it's it's an andrew yang vinyl mask and
it looks like it's a little racist i
think it looks it's not just racist it's
actually just a little bit scary like i
i look you know we look like a horror
movie whatever it's like
horror movie version of andrew yang
um but i'm going to be a ninja because
one of my boys is going to be shang chi
so i guess i'm going to be one of the
ninjas he beats up
and then evelyn is going to be
uh batgirl and our other son is going to
be batman
um so it's a very very big weekend in
the yang household evelyn's birthday
christopher's birthday um we're going to
be celebrating both independently
believe it or not they're both born on
the same day halloween so you can
imagine it's like a triple whammy
super
festive weekend ahead for us i'm not
gonna wear this um
that that thing was horrifying you guys
should check it out feel bad that i
wasted the money on it but
i i thought it would be funny too no i
mean no it's good that you it's because
you didn't surprise you i mean i i i'm
i'm but you have halloween masks on
amazon for you i'm kind of pumped that
it exists but you know if you decide to
go as me i i think you should just don't
get that mask use the
you know like uh have your base be frida
you know i thought you would laugh you
know it's actually hard to get hard to
get you to laugh unless we're talking
making fun of uh something
intellectually well i mean i got to say
man seeing like a horror movie version
of your own face like on on your
friend's face is like if i busted out of
that common mask right now and it made
you look like a serial killer i don't
know if i maybe i left some so someone
someone in the yang gang went as me for
halloween which is a check the life gold
box i think uh i didn't know i had it
but um
but it was a little um it's a different
feeling and i think the mask would have
put me over there i think so anyway
happy halloween everyone happy halloween
independent media support it we're gonna
give you a lot more to support coming
soon happy halloween from a terrifying
slightly offensive andrew yang mask and
from the real one and from the real one
love you guys later
[Music]
you